ever since I was stung as a child I had
this enormous hatred for bees if I ever
saw one around I'd either try to beat
the crap out of it or run away like a
but when I saw Jerry Seinfeld's
b-movie it certainly made me realize I
used to really like these yeah as a kid
any time there was bees on TV or in
cartoons or something I always thought
they were cool I used to love those old
down duck cartoons are the honey nut
cheerios commercials I actually really
liked bees and seeing this film reminded
me why there is sort of this creativity
and ingenuity that can be brought out of
from what they are and this movie takes
full advantage of that
using their jobs their homes their
abilities and even a coronation to make
some really memorable funny scenes so
what's the story Jerry Seinfeld is a bee
who's just graduating from bee school I
guess you'll never guess what a guy is
report card and a perfect report card
all B's yeah there's a few other bad
puns like that too but he has a problem
he doesn't like the idea that he's gonna
be assigned to one job for the rest of
his life so he decides to go out and see
the world before he does all right so
this is gonna be like ants right where
he's trying to fight for free will and
the individual and such they actually
know he comes across a woman played by
Renee Zellweger and decides to reveal
that he can actually talk and they share
a nice relationship together okay so
what everyone's gonna say you can't date
a human it's gonna be fighting against
prejudices they're actually know when he
discovers that honey is being used by
humans he decides to sue the human race
and it turns into this gigantic trial
trying to show that bees are people too
well not literally but you know let me
all right so he's gonna win the court
case and everyone's gonna be happy and
actually know the beasts it turns out
gets too much honey which means they
don't have to work anymore which means
they don't pollinate anymore which means
all the plants of the world start to die
and now it's up to sign felon Zellweger
to try and get the world back to order
you know what freakin kudos to this
movie I honestly had no idea where it
was gonna go and I love films like that
they're constantly making me guess so
the one downside is everything I was
talking about before like Seinfeld being
tied to his job never try
again the prejudice of a be dating a
human never addressed again help even
the fact that she's married to Patrick
Warburton and she's kind of having an
affair with a B you guessed it never
addressed again so I guess in that sense
it's somewhat lazy and it just sort of
stops story arts that we're starting to
get going and then just goes to
something else but what pulls it through
is the fact that has a very likable cast
very likable animation very likable
colors very creative atmospheres and
environments and it's just straight-up
funny I mean like I said before some of
the puns really do die and are pretty
lame but a lot of these jokes really hit
bull's eyes even once I think when hit
bull's eyes like I saw this be Larry
King and I'm everything in myself oh my
god really are they honestly doing this
but then they turned into something
funny you know I have a Larry King in
the human world too it's a common name
next week on be Larry King I mean he
looks like you and he has a show with
suspenders and different colored dots
behind him next week on be Larry Moe guy
glasses and there's quotes along the
bottom from the guest you're watching
even though you just heard him I mean
she not fan of Seinfeld as an actor per
se nor really Renee Zellweger but both
of them are incredibly likable in this
so I fells a good-hearted wisecracker
and so weaker serve a good-hearted
eccentric even the side characters like
Patrick Warburton Christmas Quito our
Matthew Broderick has the best friend
yes even Broderick's tolerable in this
but on top of that the ideas for this
world they create are just so likable
and I don't know it just brought me back
to being a kid again I mean listen to
some of these ideas
Wow what does that do catches that
little
honey that hangs after you pour it saves
us Millions and on top of that I think
there's something about DreamWorks
Animation that I don't know what they do
but they can really simulate motion well
particularly flying the flying scenes in
this movie really work and it really
feels like you're off the ground and
you're traveling with these creatures
even getting stuck to a car you feel
like you're really on that car being
pushed against the windshield I really
didn't expect to like be movie going
into it and yeah some parts don't work I
mean some of the animation is a little
odd particularly on the humans some of
the puns can get old and the story is
sort of all over the place but I still
liked the characters the ingenuity the
creativity and the spontaneity of it I
was pleasantly shocked by it and was
really happy to see it
it's what a few movies I wish will be
re-released on the big screen maybe even
in 3d I love to see these moments on the
big screen I think I sort of missed out
so I guess if you're looking for a movie
that has a little bit more depth or
story art to it you're probably not
gonna find it here if you're looking for
something light-hearted with some good
laughs some good voice acting and a lot
of creative designs and animation then I
say b-movie is definitely a flick to
check out
you